problema número 115 los ingresos de
mariana son 60 por ciento más que los
ingresos de juan
anotemos entonces los ingresos de
mariana son 60 por ciento 1.6 más que
los ingresos de juan y los ingresos de
juan son 40 por ciento menores que los
ingresos de alf qué porcentaje de los
ingresos de alf son los ingresos de
mariana hoy entonces anotamos aquí lo
que son los ingresos de mariana ahora
los ingresos de juan con respecto a los
de als son puntos 6 con respecto a los
de als los ingresos de juan son 40 por
ciento menores que los de alex entonces
tenemos los ingresos de al menos el 40
por ciento de sus mismos ingresos pues
va a ser igual a punto 6
por eso es que esto lo usamos aquí y
bueno esto 1.6 viene de que el ingreso
de juan más el 60 por ciento de su mismo
ingreso de juan es lo que gana mariana
así que esto viene de acá y esto viene
de acá si utilizamos la ecuación de
abajo en la de arriba vamos a ver que
los ingresos de mariana son iguales a
1.6 por los ingresos de juan y los
ingresos de juan son a su vez el punto 6
de los ingresos de alf 1.6 por punto 6
va a ser igual a 0.96 por a que son los
ingresos sociales y nos preguntan cuál
porcentaje de los ingresos sean son los
ingresos de marianna y aquí encontramos
que el ingreso de mariana es punto 6 o
lo que es lo mismo el 96% de los
ingresos reales que es nuestra opción c
siguiente problema tenemos esta tabla y
nos dicen que cada uno de los puntos de
la tabla representa una sola entrada que
indica la distancia entre un par de un
total de cinco ciudades si esta tabla se
expandiera para representar distancias
únicas entre 30 ciudades cuántos puntos
tendría la nueva tabla como ven los
puntos entre las ciudades no se duplican
si hay un punto de ave no hay un punto
debe porque estamos poniendo sólo una
entrada información de la distancia
entre la ciudad y la ciudad ve que es la
misma que entre la ciudad y la ciudad es
una información redundante por eso aquí
no se pone ningún punto
analizando la tabla vemos que la
diagonal de aquí siempre va a permanecer
vacía ya que es la conjunción de la
ciudad con sí misma y pues no hay una
distancia de una ciudad consigo misma y
de lo que queda solo se pondrían puntos
en la mitad de los cuadritos que quedan
si tenemos cinco ciudades vamos a tener
nuestra tabla de 5 x 5 cuadritos igual a
25 cuadritos
de los cuales la diagonal son 1 2 3 4 5
cuadritos es decir el mismo número que
ciudades tenemos a esta cantidad le
restamos 5 que no va a llevar nada
porque son la diagonal nos queda 20 y de
estos 20 solo la mitad van a tener
puntitos 20 entre 2 es igual a 10 20
entre 2 es igual a 10 y contar nos
tenemos con 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
cuadritos con punto ahora hagamos lo
mismo pero en lugares 5 ciudades vamos a
tener 30 nuestro cuadro nuestra tabla va
a ser de 30 x 30 30 x 30 es igual a 900
a esos 900 le vamos a restar 30
cuadritos que corresponden a la diagonal
nos va a quedar 870
y estos 870 los vamos a dividir entre 2
870 entre 2 va a ser igual
se baja el 72 por 36 aquí queda 105
ok
nos queda 435 ciudad es igual a 400
perdón 435 cuadritos no ciudades y estos
son 435 cuadros que van a tener un
puntito en ellos y esta es nuestra
opción b siguiente problema
cuál de los siguientes tiene un valor
menor a 1 veamos 2 x 7 14 14 es mayor
que 3 así que esto es mayor que 1 este
no aplica raíz cuadrada de 10 va a ser
un poquito más que 33 x 39 va a ser un
poquito mayor a 33 es mayor que 2 por lo
que esta división va a ser mayor que 1
no nos sirve 12 entre raíz de 2 no tengo
en mente cuál es el valor de raíz de 2
pero sé que es menor a 2 así que esto el
numerador es mayor que el denominador y
el resultado va a ser mayor a 1 no nos
sirve 1 entre un medio esto es lo mismo
que decir 1 por 2 entre 1 que es igual a
22 es mayor a 1 no nos sirve
ahora veamos esto 9 decimos 9 decimos al
cuadrado 9 por 9 81 entre 100 81 es
menor que 100
es menor a 1 por lo que nuestra opción
resultado es la el siguiente problema la
proporción entre la longitud y el ancho
de un rectángulo es de 3.3 a 2 si el
ancho del rectángulo es de 8 metros
cuál será la longitud aproximada del
rectángulo nos dicen entonces que
tenemos la proporción de la longitud
entre el ancho es igual a 3.3 entre 2 o
a 2 y nos dicen que en el ancho del
rectángulo es de 8 nos preguntan cuál es
el lado entonces tenemos que esto es
igual a el ancho que es de 8 metros y
queremos saber el lado correspondiente
entonces tenemos que resolver esta
ecuación la forma más sencilla es ver
cuánto le falta a 2 para llegar a 8 si
multiplicamos 2 por 4 nos va a dar 8 y
si multiplicamos este 3.3 por 4 nos dará
esta longitud
punto 3 x 4 es igual a lo de bajos 83.3
por 4 3 por 4 12 3 por 4 12 113 punto 2
metros
con respecto a 8 metros del ancho y
vemos que la opción más cercana a este
resultado es la opción c
siguiente problema problema 119 el
salario promedio de 15 personas en una
empresa es de 20.000 el salario de cinco
personas es de 25 mil cada uno y el
salario de cuatro empleados es de 16 mil
cada uno cuál es el salario promedio de
los empleados restantes no dicen el
promedio de los 15 empleados es de 20
mil lo abre veamos como 20 k el promedio
de cinco personas su salario es de 25
mil sé que es el promedio porque sé que
cada una de ellas gana exactamente 25
mil así que su promedio va a ser esta
cantidad el promedio de salario de cinco
personas es de 25 mil 25 camps y me
dicen que el promedio de cuatro personas
de su salario
cada una gana 16.000 y si son 4 que
ganan lo mismo por su promedio va a ser
de 16 mil o 16 que tratemos de encontrar
el promedio del salario de todos los
empleados sabemos que el número de
empleados totales es de 15
y para encontrar el promedio pues voy a
tomar este promedio de cada uno y lo voy
a multiplicar por el número de empleados
que tienen ese promedio de salario nos
dicen que el promedio de cinco empleados
sin completados por su salario promedio
desde 25 por 25 no voy a poner las casas
para hacer los cálculos más rápido más
el promedio de cuatro empleados cuatro
empleados que ganan dieciséis mil
el promedio de las seis personas
restantes aquí tengo nueve personas de
un total de quince es el promedio de
seis personas restantes su salario por
el número de personas que son son seis
personas y eso nos debe dar un total de
veinte mil vamos a desarrollar esto 5
por 25 es 125
+ 4 x 16 es igual a 64
+ 6 por el promedio en salario de estas
seis personas no sé cuánto ganan cada
una de estas seis personas pero sé que
el promedio de su salario es p 6 esto lo
dividimos entre 15 y debe ser igual a 20
seguimos simplificando hacemos esta suma
125 64 es igual a 189 más 6 el promedio
de 6 vamos a multiplicar 20 por 15 20
por 15 es igual a 300
restamos 189 en ambos lados me queda me
queda seis meses y es igual a 300 menos
189 menos 189 voy a hacer la operación
300 189 aquí es un 1
aquí es un 1 x 1 los 111
p 6 igual a 111 ahora todo lo divido en
36 esto entre 6 y 36 esto se va me queda
que este promedio del salario que me
interesa es igual a 111 entre 6 111
entre 6
6 por unas 6 11 6 es igual a 5 51 8 por
6 es igual a 48 me queda 3 pongo un
punto decimal aquí bajo un 0 y 5 por 6
30 30 menos 30 y 0 ya me quedo la
división exacta y el promedio es de 18.5
o lo que es lo mismo el promedio es
igual a
18.500
el promedio en salario de esas seis
personas restantes y esta es mi opción
de cocción ve y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo